eine autofähre auf dem ärmelkanal
unterwegs nach england wir hatten einen
netten ausflug gemacht jetzt wollten wir
uns auf die fahrt zurück nach hause doch
kurz hinter der hafen ausfahrt kommt es
zur katastrophe
das wasser stürzte nur so rein wie ein
güterzug
helfer eilen zum havarierten schiff
sinken zwar die leute schrien weinten
ein totales chaos und durcheinander
die kinder die im wasser trieben das war
das schlimmste für mich die ermittler
stoßen auf eine fatale fehlkalkulation
wir fragten uns wie dieses schiff sinken
konnte es hätte die fahrt über den kanal
schaffen müssen
es ging nur um geschwindigkeit die
sicherheit war egal
es war der reine wahnsinn
[Musik]
sechster märz 1987 im belgischen
zeebrügge herrscht geschäftiges treiben
der wichtige europäische verkehrs und
frachthafen ist umschlagplatz für tanker
container schiffe und fähren
bauen sie verstanden die verladung läuft
kapitän
danke
es wird abend die krude 132 meter langen
herald of free enterprise beginnt mit
der beladung des chefs
sie war eine moderne roll on roll off
wäre gebaut für beides geschwindigkeit
und wohnungen
so genannte roro fähren haben rampen an
bug und heck über die pkws und lkws an
beziehungsweise von bord fahren
das spart zeit beim verladen und zeit
ist geld um faire geschäft
der zeitdruck ist enorm um optimal
effizient zu sein muss das schiff so
schnell beladen werden wie möglich
bootsmann gehilfe mark stanley und die
crew schuften in gnadenlosem tempo ihr
arbeitstag begann vor vielen stunden in
dover
der bootsmann gehilfe dirigiert die
fahrzeuge an die korrekten parkplätze
transportiert werden lkws busse pkw und
wohnwagen
weiter weiter
das ganze muss schnell gehen und das ist
das wichtigste
die 8000 tonnen fähre hat zwei decks für
fahrzeuge an bord gibt es außerdem die
free shops restaurants cafeterias und
eine lounge in der filme gezeigt werden
weiter fahren
die 160 km lange fahrt über den
ärmelkanal dort normalerweise etwas über
vier stunden es ist die letzte tour an
diesem tag ein echt großes schiff die 16
jährige julien bonnet und ihre familie
sind auf dem heimweg nach einem
tagesausflug nach belgien die zeitungen
des sun hatte ein angebot ein trip mit
der fähre für ein pfund der zu
verschiedenen zielen das haben wir
gemacht
wir hatten einen netten tag in belgien
und jetzt freuen wir uns auf die fahrt
zurück nach hause
[Musik]
dort stürzten wir kinder uns ins
vergnügen wir rannten in alle richtungen
ins kino in die restaurants
der 18 jährige martin bahn arbeitet in
einem der board cafés
wir waren ein echt gutes team wir haben
uns gut verstanden
wir hängen auch in der freizeit zusammen
abspielten fußball
viele waren befreundet oder gingen mal
einen trinken
es war freitag am samstag wollte einer
der jungs seine verlobung feiern wir
freuen uns schon auf die partie
lkw-fahrer larry o'brien ist auf dem
rückweg nach irland er hat medizinisches
gerät geladen für den trucker ist die
überfahrt mit der kanalfähre routine
du bist zu spät nein bitte dich vor vor
und der sicherheitsmann sagte du bist zu
spät bitte ich habe alle papiere
sag mal
eine ladung ging aus deutschland direkt
nach irland ich musste nicht durch den
britischen zoll hier ist noch älter will
dann sagte er ja klar auf dein glückstag
kumpel danke alles gut ich fuhr los ein
mann winkte mich ein maintrac war der
letzte der verladen wurde
rein freut sich dass er noch mitgenommen
wird zu hause warten seine kleine
tochter und seine frau sie ist schwanger
kohle hafen station in unterwegs
[Musik]
die letzten passagiere und fahrzeuge
sind an bord wird kann auslaufen
ok
ablegen ablegen
heute abend hat sich der stress der crew
gelohnt die herald of free enterprise
liegt nur ein paar minuten später als
geplant ab
[Musik]
ich ging ins restaurant etwas zu essen
um mich sah ich jede menge leute
familien kinder ich hatte keine ahnung
warum so viel los war normalerweise sind
um diese jahreszeit nur lkw fahrer an
bord
etliche familien machten einen
tagesausflug mit der fähre wir legten
von zeebrügge ab es war richtig voll
als ich ging an deck um den blick bei
der ausfahrt aus dem hafen zu genießen
es war toll
war niemand draußen
nach nur 25 minuten fahrt und noch in
sichtweite des hafens kippt die herald
of free enterprise plötzlich nach links
es war als würde das schiff sinken erst
dachte ich dass ich mir das ein bilde
aber es passierte wirklich
wir gehen unter
auf den fahrzeug decks stimmt offenbar
etwas ganz und gar nicht
da läuft wasser die treppen runter
was ist denn jetzt los
plötzlich richtet sich die herald wieder
auf
sie kam wieder hoch aus dieser
schieflage
doch die krise ist noch nicht vorbei
erneut legt sich die herold gefährlich
auf die seite
dieses mal kam sie nicht wieder hoch sie
kenterte
hab es ging schnell unglaublich schnell
bei hella menschen alles purzelte
durcheinander was nicht niet und
nagelfest war flog durch die luft auch
menschen
[Musik]
ich realisierte gar nicht was los war
dann knallt ich gegen ein fenster
binnen 90 sekunden liegt die howard
komplett auf der seite
539 menschen sind an bord gefangen
das wasser ist eiskalt
die lage ist dramatisch
da war ein riesiges fenster es zerbarst
und das wasser stürzte nur so rein
bullaugen und türen flogen kreuz und
quer über die decks
[Musik]
gebote kamen korrekt das wasser kam von
dem fahrzeug decks nach oben über den
fahrstuhlschacht mit ihrer kraft mag es
traf mich mit der wucht eines güterzugs
ich geriet unter wasser richter ich
dachte ich wäre tot ich dachte wirklich
das war's
ich klammerte mich an den tisch hier
kannst du nicht bleiben sagte ich mir
nur ein weg führte raus ich musste nach
oben
es ist nicht so einfach in einem schiff
das auf der seite liegt nach oben zu
klettern
es war ein alptraum
ich wusste nicht wie mir geschah erst
als ich aus dem wasser auftauchte wurde
mir bewusst dass hier ist real
oben an deck william bradley
zwischenzeitlich das bewusstsein
verloren
als ich wieder zu mir kam wurde mir klar
dass das schiff gekentert war ich muss
rein und meine eltern suchen dachte ich
gehe rein sucht deine eltern
aber das ging gar nicht
es war absolut unmöglich denn das schiff
stand innen unter wasser und das wasser
stieg immer weiter da wusste ich ich
muss ins meer springen wenn ich nicht
auf dem schiff ertrinken will ich wusste
ich muss jetzt um mein leben kämpfen
tommy hat meine mutter hatte mir
schwimmen beigebracht als ich klein war
sonst hätte ich das nicht überlebt
es war eiskalt und die see war ich
wusste nicht was ich machen soll ich
versuchte ans ufer zu schwimmen dann
merkte ich das schaffe ich nicht bei den
hohen wellen
im schiff sucht o'brien und hunderte
anderer passagiere nach einem ausweg und
das eiskalte wasser steigt und steigt
das schlimmste für mich war wie die
leute schrien
die situation an bord der herald wird
immer kritischer
beim hafenmeister seebrücke geht ein
funkspruch von einem schiff in der nähe
ein
der hafenmeister setzt einen notruf ab
malcolm shakespeares erster offizier an
bord der duke of henry an
was ist dann mit der fähre los und die
jukufa läuft gerade in den hafen ein die
crew hat nach der fähre ausschau
alarmiert durch den notruf suchten alle
schiffe in der nähe nach der fähre doch
die passagiere an bord der herald können
nicht so lange warten bis hilfe
eintrifft
ich dachte nur dass sich das überleben
wollte ich wollte leben
ich fand einen schlauch und warf ihn
hoch damit er sich um einen stuhl
wackelt
heim ist natürlich klappte das erst mal
nicht ich probierte es weiter
irgendwann schaffte ich es jetzt musste
ich mich nur noch da hochziehen in einem
anderen teil des schiffs versucht martin
fans verzweifelt dem einströmenden
eisigen wasser der nordsee zu entkommen
die stühle waren am fußboden
festgeschraubt die lehnen funktionierten
wie eine art leiter ich weiß noch wie
ich mich hoch zog aber immer wieder
abstürzte ich war nass nicht frau die
meine klamotten waren vom wasser ganz
schwer
mit dem feuerwehrschlauch schafft es
larry o'brien sich aus dem wasser zu
ziehen er klettert die stühle hoch aber
nun stellt sich ihm ein weiteres problem
ein teich kletterte hoch bis zum fenster
das fenster lässt sich nicht öffnen
o'brien ist gefangen
ich zog meine stiefel aus
[Musik]
ich schlug damit gegen die scheibe immer
wieder schließlich brach sie
larry o'brien rettet sich aus dem
gefluteten restaurants erstmal
erleichtert
ich griff in meine tasche und zog 20
nach zigaretten raus
[Musik]
also keine rauchen
ich musste irgendwie auf mich aufmerksam
machen dann habe ich mein fahrzeug aus
der tasche und machte es an und aus an
und aus als ob ein schiff zwei oder drei
meilen entfernt das sehen könnte das war
eine reine panikreaktion natürlich kam
keiner
andere sind noch immer in der fähre
gefangen da du brian eine idee
zwar meint warf es unter
leute kletterten daran hoch
los bald euch packt sie in die
rettungsboote
die crew der duke of india hat
inzwischen sichtkontakt zu gekenterten
fähre
doch das wasser ist zu flach um zu
herald hinzufahren das ging nicht wegen
der sandbänke los jungs bewegt euch wir
nahmen das rettungsboot und fuhren durch
die dunkelheit
william bradley hat mühe sich in der
eiskalten nordsee über wasser zu halten
von der herald wegzuschwimmen schien
zunächst die richtige entscheidung nun
hat sie zweifel
ich schaute zurück zum schiff es lag
komplett auf der seite ein fast surreal
anblick diese war in dieser nacht die
wellen warfen mich herum langsam setzte
die unterkühlung 1 ich spürte meine
beine nicht mehr
in der herren sitzen immer noch hunderte
in der falle
es bleibt ihm nicht mehr viel zeit denn
das wasser ist eiskalt
endlich durchdringen lichter die
dunkelheit rettung
wir sahen die lichter oben auf der
steuerbordseite
wir schlugen die scheiben mit feuerwehr
exten ein um die leute da rauszuholen
wir hörten lautes klirren und krachen
wir hörten glassplittern jemand rief vor
sich da unten
sind die menschen auf dem schiff schrien
und kreischten das totale chaos
seile wurden runtergelassen eine art
schlaufe
sie riefen steckt die arme durch
haltet euch so fest wir ziemlich hoch
ich weiß noch wie ich nach oben sah sie
riefen festhalten wird sie noch hoch
helikopter schweben über der gekenterten
fähre weitere rettungsboote treffen ein
zugleich sei ein boot es war ein fischer
aus der gegend hilfe
ich winkte
sie zeigten in meine richtung dann kamen
sie zu mir hilfe hierüber bitte
[Musik]
sie zogen mich an bord
wenig wusste ich hatte überlebt dann die
erleichterung war einfach überwältigend
die rettungsmaßnahmen dauern stunden
leichen trieben vor mir im wasser
so viel zerstörung und tod in dieser
nacht
am frühen morgen ist klar dass es keine
weiteren überlebenden gibt
am ende hatten wir etwas über 300
passagiere gerettet
und wir konnten 58 tote bergen mehr
fanden wir nicht
juli in berlin hatte glück sie hat
überlebt aber was ist mit ihrer familie
coupons ein paar andere überlebende
kamen rein und dann kam mein bruder marc
wir fühlen uns in die arme und weinten
auch julians anderer stiefbruder colin
wird gerettet
wir suchen unsere eltern
und onkel david haye die frau vom roten
kreuz kam zu uns mit einem klemmbrett in
der hand und suchte unsere namen auf der
liste dann schaute sie uns an und sagte
ihr wisst dass eure eltern tot sind oder
so erfuhren wir es
[Musik]
insgesamt sterben 193 menschen bei dem
unglück
da stellen sich zwei fragen wie konnte
ein so großes schiff so schnell kentern
und wer trägt die schuld
[Musik]
die kenterung der herald of free
enterprise ist das schlimmste unglück
auf see dass großbritannien seit
jahrzehnten erlebt hat
ein ganzes land trauert
es geht widersprüchliche berichte mal
heißt es die fähre hätte die hafenmole
brandmal dass sie gestrandet die
regierung ordnete eine untersuchung an
staatsanwalt david stil leitet die
ermittlungen
die katastrophe war so schrecklich das
öffentliches interesse bestand
wie konnte das passieren es gibt
theorien die jetzt geprüft werden der
premierminister ist eingetroffen
meine herren bitte nehmen sie platz ein
expertenteam unterstützt die bei den
untersuchungen
schiffbauingenieur tom allen war am bau
des schiffs beteiligt
die herald of free enterprise war eins
von drei schwesterschiffe sie wurden als
größte und schnellste schiffe für die
passage dover calais gebaut wie konnte
das hochmoderne schiffs seien derart
tragisches ende nehmen
die herren liegt vor dem hafen
eine schmerzhafte erinnerung an die
nacht in der sie kenterte
das war schon ein beeindruckender
anblick wie dieses ziemlich große schiff
auf der seite lag und der halbe rumpf
aus dem wasser ragte
der lage der herald können die ermittler
den schiffsrumpf sofort auf
offensichtliche schäden untersuchen man
dachte zuerst dass es eine kollision gab
auf der route ist viel verkehr
ein zusammenstoß der herald mit einem
anderen schiff würde erklären dass die
fähre so plötzlich auf die seite kippte
ein großes lag unterhalb der wasserlinie
könnte der grund dafür sein dass sie so
schnell kenterte
doch die ermittler finden keinen
entsprechenden anhaltspunkt
dafür fällt ihnen etwas anderes am bug
des schiffes auf
die fünf meter großen buch klappen
stehen weit offen
geht man konnte das schiff ja von allen
seiten gut sehen die klappen waren
geöffnet das überrascht uns
augenzeugen bestätigen den ermittlern
dass die bugklappe nicht geschlossen
waren als die herren c brücke aus lief
mit offenen türen hätte das schiff nicht
ablegen dürfen
wenn ein schiff vorwärts fährt baut sich
vor ihm eine bugwelle auf die langsam
größer wird das ist eine druckwelle die
durch die fahrt des schiffes durchs
wasser entsteht das wasser wird nach
oben gedrückt und kann dann natürlich in
schiff laufen allerdings sind fähren wie
die herald so konstruiert dass kein
wasser eindringen kann auch wenn die
klappen geöffnet sind im hafen beträgt
der abstand zwischen ladebeck und
wasserlinie normalerweise 2,5 meter
dieser sogenannte freibad ist eigentlich
großzügig genug bemessen
ein schiff das die ganze überfahrt mit
offenen buch platten gemacht hat
im oktober 1983 vor ein schwesterschiff
der elf ohne zwischenfall von dover bis
calais obwohl sowohl die buk als auch
die heckklappen offenbaren sich sie vor
einfach rüber und niemand merkt es doch
es hätte ebenso gut zur katastrophe
kommen kann der kapitän forderte daher
maßnahmen damit sich das nicht
wiederholen würde da jedoch nichts
passiert war gilt das fährunternehmen
das für unnötig
die ermittler fragen sich nun warum das
schwesterschiff die passage sicher über
stand und die hält nicht mit haft wir
kamen ins grübeln wie um alles in der
welt konnte die fähre kentert sie hätte
es auch mit offenen buch klappen über
den ärmelkanal schaffen müssen
die herren wird aufgerichtet bei der
untersuchung des wracks entdecken die
ermittler weiter nichts ungewöhnliches
die offenen buch klappen müssen das
unglück verursacht haben
aber wie
sind wir soweit toni pkws und lkws in
reihe auf der suche nach antworten
konzentrieren sich die experten auf das
schwesterschiff der herd sie wollen das
unglück simulieren um herauszufinden
warum
193 menschen sterben mussten
inzwischen sind zwei monate vergangen
seit die herald of free enterprise in
der nähe des hafens von zeebrügge
kenterte
sind wir bald soweit
um herauszufinden wie genau es dazu kam
spielen die ermittler die letzten
minuten vor der katastrophe noch einmal
durch mit der pride of free enterprise
dem schwesterschiff der herald
simulieren sie die fahrt die beiden
fähren sind baugleich
die breit wird maximal beladen
mehrere kameras werden an bord
installiert jede phase des experiments
soll aufgezeichnet werden
kameras montiert dann lasst uns anfangen
toni moral koordiniert den versuch
wir hatten geräte an bord um leistung
und geschwindigkeit des schiffs zu
messen beobachter verfolgten das schiff
vom ufer aus
wir wollten alles ganz genau nach
stellen und bei gleicher thiele und zur
gleichen tageszeit wie die herald aus
sie brücke auslaufen
der wichtige unterschied dieses mal sind
die bu klappen geschlossen
die ermittler interessieren sich vor
allem für den freibord den abstand
zwischen wasserlinie und fahrzeug deck
wie kann das hafenwasser 13 meter höher
liegende deck the
halls erst das untersuchen sie den
verlade prozessen seebrücke
wie sieht es mit den ballasttanks auf
rang 14 2 168 tonnen tank 3 42 tonnen
sei
sehr gut
die herald hat zwei lade decks doch am
hafen zeebrügge gibt es nur eine
laderampe
sie nutzten die gleiche rampe für beide
decks oben und unten
das war jedoch nur möglich wenn sie den
bug beschwerten und das schiff so
unterdrückten erst dann konnte das
oberdeck beladen werden
vor dem auslaufen begann die crew damit
die ballers tanks leerzupumpen
beim unfall hatte die herald jedoch noch
tonnenweise ballast in den tanks
für das experiment läuft das
schwesterschiff crowd of free enterprise
nun mit einer ähnlichen menge ballast
aus tanks 14 und 3 bei 260 tonnen
wieviel freibord haben wir das drückt
den bug einen halben meter runter war
der zusätzlicher ballast der grund für
das fluten der decks
fribourg dadurch verringerte sich der
freibord der abstand zwischen der
wasserlinie am bug und dem fahrzeug dem
auslaufen aus dem hafen zeebrügge war er
dadurch bereits reduziert
mit einem nun um über einen halben meter
verringerten freibord verlässt die fähre
den trafen die ermittler schauen genau
hin
loki mit mehreren kameras beobachteten
wir genau die bugwelle aus verschiedenen
perspektiven
die ballasttanks sind gefüllt die fähre
voll beladen und die kamera bilder
zeigen klar dass das wasser dennoch
nicht die höhe der bbu klappen erreicht
die ermittler vermuten dass der hafen
selbst eine rolle beim unglück gespielt
haben könnte
mit nur 16 meter tiefe ist der hafen von
zeebrügge relativ flach
die breite fast sechs meter tiefgang
durch den geringen abstand zwischen
rumpf und hafengrund wird das schiff
noch etwas weiter nach unten gezogen
[Musik]
wenn sich nur wenig wasser zwischen kiel
und meeresboden befindet wird das wasser
beschleunigt und dadurch sinkt das
schiff ein stück ab
[Musik]
dieser sogenannte squad effekt durch den
bug einen weiteren halben meter tiefer
ins wasser doch selbst im seichten
hafenbecken würde so kein wasser aufs
ladebeck gelangen
der freibord war zwar gering aber immer
noch ausreichend
können wir auf volle fahrt gehen die
ermittler bitten die crew den hafen mit
der gleichen geschwindigkeit zu
verlassen wie die herren endlich finden
sie das letzte puzzleteil
guck mal das wasser erreicht plötzlich
die bugklappe
die kameras zeigten deutlich dass die
bugwelle war entsprechender
geschwindigkeit hoch genug steigt das
deckt zu fluten wenn die bugklappe offen
sind
damit war das schicksal der herold
besiegelt
tonnenweise ballast in den bug tanks ein
flacher hafen und das höhere tempo haben
den freibord zu weit verringert
rother in den ersten 15 sekunden drängen
40 tonnen wasser pro sekunde ins schiff
und das wasser lief direkt aufs fahrzeug
deckt
überflutete damit die gesamte fracht der
fähre
das schiff kenterte innerhalb von einer
minute eine minute das ist dramatisch
ein grund warum die herren zu schnell
kenterte war ihre konstruktion
wie die meisten roro fähren hatten auch
ihre fahrzeug decks keine chance wenn
sie geflutet werden breitet sich das
wasser auf der ganzen fläche des tags
aus bewegt sich das wasser im schiff
sind die effekte gravierend
nehmen sie ein tablett und setzen das
unter wasser solange sie es ganz still
halten passiert nichts aber sobald sie
es nur ein bisschen schief halten fließt
das ganze wasser in eine richtung
stellen sie sich das auf einem schiff
mit 50 meter breite vor in dem ein meter
wasser steht sobald sich das schiff auf
eine seite neigt verschiebt sich das
gewicht des wassers das nennt man frei
oberfläche effekt eine
gewichtsverlagerung von einer schiff
seite auf die andere
dieser effekt führt dazu dass sich das
schiff nach dem ersten kippen wieder
aufrichtet
desto wenn das gewicht jedoch zu groß
wird kann sich das schiff nicht mehr
aufrichten und es kennt hat
ihr schwarm ein paar tausend tonnen
wasser von einer schiff seite zur
anderen und das hat natürlich enorme
wirkung
die herald kennt hat innerhalb von
sekunden
die geöffneten bo klappen hatten zum
wassereinbruch geführt fast 200 menschen
sterben
doch warum standen sie überhaupt offen
und wer dafür verantwortlich
wir fragten uns nun vor allem warum sie
offenbaren was natürlich nicht so sein
sollte der kapitän des schiffs gerät ins
visier der ermittler warum lief er aus
ohne dass die glatten gesichert waren
wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass die
bugklappe der herald anders konstruiert
waren als auf den meisten anderen fairen
damals bei den meisten anderen fairen
klappte das burgtor hoch man konnte es
von der brücke aus sofort sehen die
herald of free enterprise hatte aber
flügeltüren die zur seite aufklappen
deswegen konnte man von der brücke nicht
so leicht sehen ob sie offenbar
die ermittler finden heraus dass es
keine warnleuchte gab die dem kapitän an
zeigte das depot klappen offenbaren oben
auf der brücke konnte er nicht sehen
dass er sein schiff ins verderben
steuern würde
eine untersuchung soll licht ins dunkel
bringen
wichtigster zeuge ist kapitän david
er wurde bei der havarie selbst schwer
verletzt unter ihm hat sich nur noch
vage
warum legten sie mit offenen buch
klappen ab
ich weiß es nicht mehr
ich dachte das wäre gar nicht möglich
ablegen wir legen ab liest sich
jedenfalls sicher dass ihm nicht
gemeldet wurde dass es ein problem gab
bei unserer untersuchung stellten wir
fest dass die herald ein negatives
berichtssystem hatte
bei einem negativen berichts system geht
der kapitän davon aus dass alles in
ordnung ist solange ihm nichts anderes
gemeldet wird wir forderten daher die
einführung eines positiv meldung systems
der diensthabende offizier auf dem deck
musste der brücke bestätigen dass die
klappen geschlossen sind und das schiff
ablegen kann
die ermittlungen ergeben dass der
kapitän sich nicht vergewisserte dass
die bo klappen zu wahren
und der erste offizier
enterprise sales aufgaben gehört die
überwachung des be und entladen des
schiffs
weiter weiter
sables aussage liefert den ermittlern
eine bedenkliche information
ich habe die steuerung der bug klappen
verlassen
[Musik]
ein hafen station zu station
hin unterwegs
wenige minuten vor der geplanten abfahrt
der herald verlässt sable das ladebeck
obwohl die bugklappe noch geöffnet sind
die
ermittlungen ergeben dass sable die
steuerung frühzeitig verlassen musste um
rechtzeitig seinen anderen posten zu
erreichen
ablegen wir legen ab wir legen ab denn
beim auslaufen musterhafte brücke sein
es gab widersprüchliche anweisungen der
erste offizier sollte auf dem fahrzeug
deckt das schließen der klappe
überwachen und gleichzeitig beim ablegen
auf der brücke sein
der offizier war hin und hergerissen
zwischen der gewährleistung der
sicherheit unten auf dem autodeck und
oben auf der brücke
die untersuchung ergibt dass sich die
abfahrt um mehrere minuten verzögert
hätte wenn der erste offizier auf dem
deck geblieben wäre bis die klappen
geschlossen waren
und tatsächlich war die crew sieben
monate vor der avery von der reederei
aufgefordert worden 15 minuten früher
abzulegen
dieser druck lastete auf dem ersten
offizier wenn er dafür die pünktlichkeit
verantwortlich
die konkurrenz in der branche ist groß
insofern ist der druck möglichst schnell
zu sein nachvollziehbar aber
dabei dachte niemand an die probleme die
sich ergeben wenn jemand gleichzeitig
auf zwei posten sein soll
wir waren geschockt als wir diese
anweisung sei
darüber dass da ein manager tatsächlich
tempo über sicherheit stellt
der kapitän bemerkt nichts der erste
offizier keine zeit zu prüfen
nun sprechen die ermittler mit hilfs
putzmann mag stanley
der bootsmann hatte mehrere aufgaben
doch seine wichtigste war die klappen
vor dem auslaufen aus dem hafen zu
schließen
danke dass sie gekommen sind haben sie
die buch klappen geschlossen
[Musik]
marc stanley gesteht dass sie am 6 märz
1987 versäumte seine aufgabe zu erfüllen
der für das schließen der klappe
zuständige gab zu dass er dies nicht
getan hatte
klar mag stanley sagt aus dass er seinen
posten verließ und in die pause ging
seine schicht hatte vor stunden auf der
anderen seite des ärmelkanals begonnen
menschen machen fehler egal wie
diszipliniert oder wie gut ausgebildet
sie sind menschen ermüden und müde
menschen machen fehler stanley geht in
seine kabine und tee zu trinken und
schläft ein
er wacht erst wieder auf als das schiff
kentert
das ganze land hört denn ist aussage und
ist entsetzt
die untersuchung ergibt dass die
bugklappe offen bleiben weil ein
mitglied der crew eingeschlafen war und
es niemanden gab der sie kontrollierte
es gab keine redundanz niemand sprang
ein wenn einer einen fehler machte
eine übermüdete crew und eile um ein
paar minuten zu starren kostete fast 200
menschen das leben es ist ein weckruf
für die branche die vier unternehmen
werden aufgefordert maßnahmen zu
ergreifen die verhindern dass sich eine
solche tragödie wiederholt
schließlich erscheint der
untersuchungsbericht zum untergang der
herald of free enterprise
die schuld an der tragödie tragen
demnach mitglieder der crew und die
unternehmensleitung
richter schien warf der 1000 reederei
einen durch und durch schlampiges
management vor es gäbe keine führung und
ein vakuum auf mittlerer ebene
das berichtssystem und die
standardabläufe an bord werden
umgestellt der untersuchungsbericht
fordert überdies den umbau der roro
fähren
wir wollten die sicherheit erhöhen die
wahrscheinlichkeit reduzieren dass sich
so etwas wiederholt
denn eine kleinigkeit hätte die havarie
verhindert
sie hätten ein warnsignal installieren
können das anzeigt dass die klappen
geschlossen sind
das gericht empfahl dass eine solche
anzeige auf der brücke montiert wird
das fehlende licht signal war jedoch
nicht der einzige konstruktionsfehler
der zum kentern der herren trug um in
einer heftig umkämpften branche zu
bestehen werden roro fähren so
konstruiert dass fahrzeuge so schnell
wie möglich an bord und wieder an land
fahren kann das hat seinen preis
dieser schiffstyp ist extrem anfällig er
ist auf optimale effizienz ausgelegt
tatsächlich nimmt man dafür gewisse
risiken in kauf insbesondere die offenen
fahrzeug decks die sich durchgehend
links und quer durch das ganze schiff
erstreckt
der untersuchungsbericht schlägt vor
dass auf den fahrzeug decks shots
eingezogen werden um den freier
oberfläche effekt zu reduzieren
bestimmte gruppen innerhalb der seefahrt
machten ziemlichen druck fähren mit
offenen decks sollten nicht mehr in
betrieb gehen
doch in der branche stößt die idee auf
massiven widerstand
roro fähren geht es uns um schlag tempo
du fährst auf der einen seite ein auf
der anderen raus das erfordert
eigentlich ein offenes deck
die filmindustrie versucht
geschwindigkeit und damit zu geld und
sicherheit unter einen hut zu bekommen
die überlebenden leiden weiter unter den
folgen der dramatischen nacht
ich bin vier monate lang gefahren nur um
mir zu beweisen dass ich es schaffe
meine familie war völlig fertig
schließlich haben wir es hinter uns
gelassen aber ich musste einfach ich
musste mich
ist klar dass ich nie mehr zur see
fahren werde im jahr nach dem unglück
habe ich es noch einmal versucht aber
ich hatte einfach solche angst ich kann
das nicht mehr ich habe gekündigt
das wird mich bis zu meinem tod
begleiten wenn du einmal traumatisiert
bist wirst du es nicht mehr los wir
sollten die leichen identifizieren mann
brachte uns zu einer sporthalle da sah
ich meine mutter liegen es hieß ich
dürfte sie nicht anfassen ich habe
trotzdem meine hand auf ihre schulter
gelegt um mich zu verabschieden um ihr
zu sagen dass ich sie liebe
[Musik]
die kinder die im wasser trieben das war
das schlimmste für mich
da dachte ich an meine kleine tochter
und was ich für ein glück hatte dass sie
zu hause war
larry o'brien hat in jener nacht 40
menschen das leben gerettet ohne ihn und
die anderen passagiere und
crewmitglieder die anderen menschen
helfen hätte es noch mehr tote gegeben
die besatzung der herald of free
enterprise wurde viel kritisiert zu
unrecht sie taten weit mehr als ihre
pflicht
einige von ihnen opferten ihr leben um
andere zu retten das sollten wir nie
vergessen
was ich getan habe hätte jeder andere
auch getan es ist halt so wie es ist
wenn es morgen wieder passieren würde
würde ich genauso reagieren man weiß
nicht wie man reagiert ich weiß es
jedenfalls nicht
ich brauchte zwei jahre bis ich wieder
normal leben konnte
einen tag erleben ohne schmerz ohne leid
ohne dauernd zu denken dass es hätte
ganz anders kommen können
darauf an einem einzigen tag habe ich
meine ganze familie verloren ich bin als
kind los gereist und als erwachsene
zurückgekommen ich wusste dass mein
leben nie mehr dasselbe sein wird
[Musik]